hey everyone is sayers read sooner sorry
and home and in this video I'm going to
show you how to dawn sterile gloves the
very first thing we want to do is wash
your hands then select a pair of gloves
that will fit you because these come in
various sizes once you have your gloves
you will open them up like that and you
will notice these little flaps these
flaps will assist you and opening up the
glove so you won't contaminate them so
just put your fingers underneath them
and just pull it open and remember you
have two inches to grab around this
field and you do not want to cross two
inches because you will contaminate the
field so just go around and just gently
open the gloves up and you have your
right glove and your last glove and
these are the cuffs which we will be
touching and they will become unfair oh
but we do not want to touch the outer
part of the glove so first what we're
going to do is we're going to glove or
dominant hand and I my dominant hand is
my right hand so I'm going to glove that
first so what I want to do is I'm going
to take my left hand and I'm going to
grab the cuff of the right part of the
glove and I'm going to slide my hand
into the glove and I'm going to slightly
tuck my son-in so it'll be easier
getting the glove on so I got the cuff
I'm going to slide my hand in and then
just put my fingers out and then I'm
just going to roll that down the cuff
making sure I don't touch the outer part
just so it slides up my arm okay now
this is sterile do not touch anything
other than what you're going to be doing
with this glove because it will become
contaminated now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just simply take my fingers
underneath the last glove and get under
there so I can glove my left hand so
just sliding underneath now I'm going to
make sure I keep this thumb away because
I'm going to slide it over my left hand
and I'm going to slightly just tuck my
left thumb in again and just slide
underneath the glove and I'm pushing
with this part of the glove so it will
go over my hand
and have that and then I'm just going to
just gently roll it down without
touching my arm and I have the gloves on
and they are sterile so now I'm ready to
perform my procedure thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos